[Music]
there's been an outpouring of grief and
solidarity in the Kashmir Valley
hundreds of people in rajori attended
the funeral of those killed in two
attacks this week neighbors have been
visiting the Sharma household two
children were killed in a blast on
Monday morning this was hours after
their Uncle Deepak was gunned down at
home his brother-in-law witnessed the
attack
two gunmen barged into our house and
opened fire on them one was shot many
times the other was shot but managed to
get out of the house they kicked them
many times to check if he was alive
thankfully he is recovering now
there's growing angle in Indian
administered Kashmir some areas in the
valley are observing shutdowns people
are demanding more security for
religious minorities their Affairs armed
conflict may be returning Kashmir is
claimed in full by India and Pakistan
but governed by the two Nations and
parts attacks against civilians were
common in Indian administered Kashmir
when armed Rebellion against new delhi's
rule was at its peak the governing BJP
has blamed Pakistan for the recent
incidents
our party is fulfilling its Zero
Tolerance policy towards terrorism the
situation has improved from before
Pakistan is frustrated he used to send
terrorists across the border but
recently we caught a lot of ammunition
so they're trying to ruin the harmony of
the region but our party will finish
terrorism here
rise in attack which shouldn't
Kashmir looks unsafe so let's not look
at it through the prism of uh communal
politics or to the communal angle but
unfortunately that is how the things are
being looked in India as as for the last
so many years India's counter-terrorism
agency is investigating the attacks the
government has deployed more troops in
rajari about 155 kilometers south of the
largest city of Srinagar to prevent
further attacks as the victim's families
pick up the pieces they hope they'll get
Justice Al Jazeera